الى مؤتمر صحفي لوزير الدفاع الامريكي في
الهند
ولا
يات المحيطات الهند قادره على مواجهه
الصين
[موسيقى]
مجددا فيما يخص اوكرانيا احيلكم الى
الاوكرانيين
يجيبوا نتحدث عن ما نراه هون نرى عمليات
مستمره في محيط المخموت وداخلها نرى
زياده في الانشطه هناك وفي المنطقه
قد يكون هناك امور مختلفه مع تحسن الطقس
لقد قلنا في السابق ان الطقس
يشكل عاملا يؤخذ في الاعتبار نريد ان
نتاكد ان اوكرانيا تجري استطلاعات
وتتمكن من القيام بمناورات ناجحه ماذا
تفعل اين متى وكيف
برايي ينبغي ان نسمح للاوكرانيين ان
يتحدثوا بانفسهم عن عملياتهم فيما يخص
السؤال الثاني
يقال انها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اعطت معلومات استخباراتها للهند في
مواجهاتها على الحدود مع الصين ما هي
الخطوات التي تتخذونها لتتاكدوا ان
الهند قادره على مواجهه
لن نتطرق او نخص في تفاصيل ما نتبادله
ولكنكم تعرفونها نحن دائما ما نعطيه
المعلومات قدر الامكان وقدر مستطاعنا
اي خطوات
محدده نتخذها او لا نتخذها
لن اتطرق اليها هنا
لقد ذكرت زياده التعاون في مجال صنع
الفضاء
وضروره ان يعمل الشركاء اكثر برايك الى
ايه مدى سوف تخلق الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وشركائها قاعده
متكامله نظرا الى ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه غالبا ما تسعى الى الحفاظ على
تكنولوجيتها العسكريه
[تصفيق]
مازلنا حاذرين فيما يخص التكنولوجيا
ونشارك هذه التكنولوجيا مع الدول التي
نؤمن بها ونثق بها فعلا
ترونز رغبه متزايده
لدينا بمشاركه المزيد مع شركائنا هنا في
الهند ادعمنا نظرتم الى بعض الامور التي
نعمل عليها انطوان نحن نصف هذه
الفتره
بانها مليئه
عواقب او التداعيات وهناك فرص لزياده
القدرات
كل ذلك ايجابي اذا ما نظرنا
الى ما ينبغي فعله من اجل ان نواصل العمل
لتكون منطقه الهند الهادئ حره ومنفتحه
لدينا هذه الرؤيه ونتشاركها مع الهند ودول
اخرى في المنطقه تحدثنا عن
امور كثيره في سنغافوره يوم السبت
يشجعنا دائما ان الهند تواصل تنويع
معداتها منذ
عقد ونواصل العمل معها من اجل زياده
قدراتها اكثر
شكرا جزيلا
شراكه بين الهند والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على انها فيها تدعيه هل توافق
او فيها الكثير من الامكانات وهي العوائق
امام تحقيق هذه
الافاق وفيما يخص ذلك قدره روسيا على
تسليم الاسلحه تراجعت بسبب الاوضاع في
اوكرانيا هل تستغل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ذلك
هل من الدقيق ان نقول ان العلاقه بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والهند كما
وصفها
نحن ديمقراطيتان من الديمقراطيات الاكبر
في
العالم هناك قدرات
واحتمالات افاق كبيره في هذا البلد نحن
كما لدينا لديهما الاراء والافكار نفسها
قد نقلق تداعيات دائما مستدمره انما علينا
ان نتاكد ان المنطقه تبقى مفتوحه وحره
ونشجع على التجاره وحريه التنقل السلع
والافكار